[Music]
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark barnard oh [ __ ] we're
ready to do this folks thanks for coming
out and and being here with us as always
at the scum and villainy Cantina
on Hollywood Boulevard right here in the
heart all I would put your hands
together so the folks at home know
you're real how are you sir
I'm great man how are you so good I had
a very Hollywood e-type day but I know
you got a story Hollywood eats at bay we
get to my story later all right really
yeah yeah you go first I did I was just
saw mark right before we came out I was
like I had such a [ __ ] Hollywood
e-type today like I I went to two
meetings today one was a pitch for a
project that I would just be a director
on wonderful project wonderful script by
a tried and true talent and I went in
with a producer who's also like made a
zillion [ __ ] things and movies that
have made hundreds of million disolve of
dollars and we went to Netflix haha the
new Netflix plays and everyone's always
like you should do [ __ ] with Netflix
including me I say the same [ __ ]
thing as if it was that simple but there
its massive like I I've not been there
for a pitch in a while I pitched there
over the like I was telling the people I
went in with today I was like they they
were like have you ever gone Netflix I
said you have four times this year I
think and they were like really and I
detailed each time I said and each time
man they're just they're always so nice
and what they don't [ __ ] buy from me
at least so I you know I don't know I
said it's weird too because I know Ted
the guy that runs the joint and I see
him like every time I've gone into pitch
he'll pop through the lot of through the
lobby and he's like oh she had calves
what are you doing we sit there and
chitchat and then he's like what are you
bringing and I say this is like oh I
hope we buy it and they never do so
so I told the folks I was with today I
was like as long as we don't run into
Ted in the lobby we might have a shot
man because he could just buy it Jesus I
hope we buy it no you're [ __ ] Santa
Claus you could deliver if you want hope
the elves make more toys for you no [ __ ]
you
buy it I guess I don't have that kind of
relationship to just be like you [ __ ]
buy a Ted it never occurred to me to try
that approach so we go to Netflix which
had used to be over in Beverly Hills but
now is like like Los Feliz right yeah
even more insulting Lee used to be like
you drive nearly an hour get there and
they'd be like no and then you drive an
hour home now it's like three blocks
from my house to get rejected quick you
go there and you realize like oh [ __ ]
like this is what they do with all our
money it's massive the lobby you walk
into is like a giant video wall that
surrounds the room so like when I walked
in it was advertisement for what's the
show they do but at the crown is it yeah
so you walked into Buckingham Palace and
there were two dogs on this video wall
it was [ __ ] nuts it was impressive
and then as they took us up to the
meeting like one point we were waiting
on one floor and then when we went up to
the meeting floor every floor had a
lunch room and everyone was eaten and I
was like I missed my calling like I
really I should have worked at Netflix
man like my god so we went up we had our
pitch and it's it's weird I've been in
this business for like almost 25 years
that's coming up on and that place like
makes me feel small and scared they
don't try they're not intimidating on
purpose but it's just like I don't know
for some reason I go in there I lose all
of my nerve I forget who the [ __ ] I am
and what I've done and any confidence I
have goes out the [ __ ] door it's
crazy so you know the people that I were
going I was going to pitch with they're
like how are you I'm like oh I'm great
in the room and I wasn't at all like I
don't know that I was helpful in the
pitch at all and [ __ ] so I left and it
like when I
I was like [ __ ] man like maybe I'm over
like maybe I missed it like you know the
[ __ ] I was gonna say the facts but
what that would mean I'm definitely
[ __ ] over if I'm referring to [ __ ]
facts but maybe I missed the email or
the memo that my [ __ ] just don't play
anymore and it's weird because I'm like
rabid I go out on tour all the time and
like we have sold-out houses and [ __ ]
but maybe just in this business like
that's it so I was driving around after
the Netflix meeting they just go I'm
like well it was fun while it lasted
like you know you had a real good run
and [ __ ] like that and like you got to
star in a movie a couple of them [ __ ] if
it ends if it's over it's [ __ ] done
then I went to another meeting in the
afternoon with people that want to make
Jay and Silent Bob reboot which is the
movie we're gonna make in the spring and
it was like a hundred and eighty degrees
for Matt and I'm not saying like Netflix
they weren't mean to us or anything like
that but the vibe there is just like
look at this do you think we need you
you know but the second meeting I went
to their like oh we couldn't do this
without you and like oh your voice is
original and [ __ ] like that I don't know
it was weird I went to a low and then
back to I wouldn't even say a high but
back to a fairly decent place in the
span of like two hours so then later on
this evening I was dropping my kid off
she's going to an acting class and she
was like how was your day and you know
it's a five minute ride and I'm [ __ ]
Lleida blur with a 12 minute story you
know so we pulled up in front of the
place and I'm still talking and [ __ ]
like that
and so I'm like you know it's just weird
like I picked like a career of you know
a business where rejection is a part of
the process like every every [ __ ] it's
more rejection than acceptance I said
and that's why like I've always gone
indie because you don't have to wait for
permission or have somebody bless you or
you don't feel like you're going
hat-in-hand cuz you're doing your own
thing so you know my daughter's like you
realize I'm about to go to an acting
class
I said yeah she goes I know a [ __ ]
thing or two about rejection and she
left
so she'd put it in perspective for me
man and also as I drove back from
chopping her off I'm like God like you
sound like such a baby like you know
what I'm saying like as i sat there
talking to her about it I'm sure she was
just like which one of us is the [ __ ]
child here but but that was my weird
Hollywood day I went to both ends of the
[ __ ] spectrum one where and again
they weren't like you suck I just felt
like so out of place I felt like wow the
world has truly passed me by my only
real interaction with this company will
forever be me paying for it every month
to watch Netflix that's our relationship
you know you give us money goodbye but
see that's where you went wrong why you
have the power when they ask who the
hell do you think you are you say I am a
subscriber sir you work for me my money
makes all this possible bring me a
bottle of water the biggest one you have
that is the approach that should be
taken where I'm like don't I pay your
salary take my show what did you do
today I went to a food court in a in a
mall by my house because I like to write
in places where there's enough white
noise that it kind of helps create this
little like pocket of just static right
and like a good food court coz so based
on this if you write well with white
noise then you could write a [ __ ]
bestseller at a Justin Bieber concert
thank you well done maybe that's why the
business is done with me the Bieber
jokes fever jokes so I was walking
through the mall and and I passed by
this black dude who's walking the other
way and you're familiar with them not
right
no said how the nod works so the nod is
the thing when two black people who've
never met each other before are passing
each other anywhere walking hallway
office whatever you just give little
just a nod you will not back move on
your day and my wife asked me once it's
like what's what's the not all about
she's Irish and and I'm like it is it is
the silent acknowledgement of shared
struggle is what that is or it is in
case the [ __ ] race war breaks
I got you however you'd like to
interpret those two so it's kind of like
a low hardest to the pro meetings it's
like I see you it's good and so I'm
walking into small right this guy comes
ahead instead of the night he goes Black
Panthers in a month yo literally swear
to God never met this guy in my entire
life he is greeting to me was Black
Panthers in a month yo looks like you're
[ __ ] right it is a man Chazz smiles
galore for the rest of the [ __ ]
dinner because that is now the new
what's up Black Panthers in a month you
know and it's I don't I honestly don't
think that anybody's ready for how much
money this movie is gonna make it sir
they're already talking about I'm the
pre-sales are based on civil war higher
than any other Marvel movie it's it's
gonna do that thing that Wonder Woman
did which was you know and I'm not even
just saying that only women went to go
see Wonder Woman although even if they
did it would still make eight hoja
million dollars because there's more
women than men and that's how that works
but if every black person goes to see
Black Panther nine times and we will
because we're all taking a month off and
if they all take their mom their brother
their sister their uncle everybody
they've ever met to go see Black Panther
eight times because we're all taking the
month off this movie makes like a
billion dollars it just does because
it's it's this weird social movement
where it's a moment that nobody quite
could have predicted
except for Marvel because they
bankrolled it because they know more
than I do but [ __ ] man February I'm not
prepared nobody's prepared they've been
trying though to make the movie for a
while to be fair like going yeah for a
while but like we were not prepared when
Luke Cage broke Netflix and I don't
think we're gonna be prepared when Black
Panther breaks movies but that was my
weird [ __ ] day where I realized that
there's now a new greeting on the street
do you think that dude recognized you is
like oh that's the guy that talks about
[ __ ] like this I don't think so only
because when that does happen and it
happens increasingly rarely like yo take
the show that I always get something
like man I love fat man cool that's
awesome man
stopping by it was just black Mathers in
a month yo that's it
I'm looking forward to the public
countdown so I'm gonna get a black man
that Black Panthers in 28 days yo black
man is in 128 hours yo what the [ __ ] is
doing man the ayah I today when when I
was pulling on to the Netflix lot the
dude I went to roll my window down give
him my license and he goes where you
going mr. Smith and I said oh hi I said
I'm going to Netflix and then I was with
somebody else so he asked for his
license so as the guys punching my name
and he goes cash you question and I said
yeah he goes what'd you think of Justice
League and then I we got into this like
mini conversation about it and then as I
pulled on to the lot the guy I was with
he's from I don't even know why it's
Mitch Albom the guy that wrote Tuesdays
with Maurey and he's a sports reporter
from Detroit so he's just like oh my god
what a difference he's like when I'm in
Detroit like wherever you stop people
like let me ask you this man Howard a
Red Wings doing this year how're they
gonna do how are they gonna do he's like
but in this town people literally stop
others and say what did you think of
Justice League and I was like that might
be because of the podcast you know and
also I'm known to kind of like and
comment on that stuff
but that happens wherever I go now
people don't talk to me about my [ __ ]
anymore they're always just like what
you think of Justice League
you know like TSA agents all the time as
they're patting me down they're just
like would you think of Thor you know I
don't know as exciting as this pat-down
it's nice though that there's that
common language used to be secret
language well me and Mark were younger
there weren't that many people weren't
as public with their letting their geek
flag fly yeah there was a lot of
closeted nerds and closeted nerds but
there was a lot of just what are you
doing not reading comics what are you
really doing not reading comics I swear
but now what are you doing reading
comics yo now there's not even that now
it's just like Black Panther thirty days
neither are you ready what you gonna
wear there's little a meme online just
like what are you wearing to the Black
Panther opening night what are you
wearing uh I got a I got to see if my
dad as an old dashiki left I figure I
will be blacker than I've ever been
50 I have also started planning my
wardrobe I'll be wearing a hockey jersey
[Laughter]
all right man we got news we do have
some news
you know what premiered tonight one
month from Black Panther Black Lightning
oh did it what after flash on CW after
flash on the CW did I suppose I can't
ask if anybody's seen it cuz you're all
[ __ ] here so I saw the pilot oh I did
now here this is what I this is this was
a sneaking suspicion I had you can
confirm it okay go and I'm probably way
off what I got from the marketing
campaign was we're trying to hide the
fact that Black Lightning is really
gonna be the girls it's not gonna be
this man the whole time it's gonna begin
with him but it's more gonna be shifted
on to them because it was very weird to
see CW have a leading character who
looked like he wasn't 18 no he's an old
man yeah he's like in his flemming 40s
and 40s his old man for CW yeah huge the
show it's absolutely setting up his
daughters Anissa and Jennifer who in the
comics are thunder and lightning I
believe is that how that works out who
have [ __ ] superpowers because of
course their dad is a superhero that's
the way comic books work but it's not
there yet a lot of it is about you know
daughters rebelling against a father who
was a principal of the school they went
to whose father is is very much invested
in not allowing this special to flourish
in his house because the special gets
you in trouble I was
superhero wants right it is like what if
Luke Cage was a principal in a high
school and Luke Cage if you remember
half of that show was about
recalcitrance it was about not willing
to be the hero that you knew your
neighborhood needed it's about a dude
not answering the call yeah it's true
and so much of at least the pilot of
black of black lightning almost a black
panther because it's so easy the pilot
of black lightning is Jefferson Pierce
refusing to be black lightning until bad
[ __ ] happens to his kids and he's got a
strap on the guns one last time in the
dumbest costume I've ever seen he looks
like a VW Bug from a Pixar movie like
there's just weird [ __ ] dayglo
lightning stripes and [ __ ] in it lights
up like it's it's you remember do you
remember the Running Man
the Arnold Schwarzenegger yes when he
fights dynamo that the the Russian like
opera singer who's got the [ __ ]
lightning bolts and all that [ __ ] it is
only a little bit better than that I'm
hoping this was like Mark 1 on the black
lightning outfit test right but it's a
it is a show that is that is attempting
to be socially relevant in a way that CW
shows usually aren't like it is very
directly addressing things like driving
while black it's directly addressing
things like guns and gangs and schools
and how all of those things sort of
collide and collude to make for
dangerous environments it's very much
dealing with with you know police
involvement in that kind of stuff and I
don't know as you saw the pilot but I
think it's kind of strong yeah yeah I
would watch more is it it does he stick
around or do you think it shifts to them
because he is way outside there he is
audience generally is I think he sticks
around I think there's a world in which
he becomes old Batman to his daughters
who will then be the heroes every now
and again he will you know strap on the
guns that's the impression I got when I
watched the first trailer like now I
think they're gonna play a more central
role in the show yeah but I think I
think it's gonna be over time I don't
think you see that in the first season
really yeah I think they still want to
establish that whole thing like make it
work make it fly and then change it
I watched Supergirl last night Supergirl
came back
from the midseason hiatus and it was
dope they did the Legion of super-heroes
who are a variation of the Legion of
super-heroes they had Mon L they had
Saturn girl and they had Brainiac 5 and
they all put on their rings at one point
and they all fought and there was
actually a really sweet piece one of the
writers was Eric who had written the
episodes that I did up the Supergirl and
they there was this piece in there where
they were you know they're from the
future and the how they're playing the
league is that Monell was on the show
last season and then he had she had to
get him off the planet Cara the super
girl had to get mana off the planet cuz
a let bomb had gone off and he's ad
Aksumite and that's what killed Dax am I
so even though they loved each other she
put him into her pod that she had come
to earth and and set him off to get as
far away from the earth as possible so
he can breathe and live and stuff he
wound up going through a black hole and
got lost and she'd been waiting for him
he still hasn't returned and then
episode three or four of this season or
five or six or something like that they
revealed that there was a ship under
National City and that ship was the
Legion ship and in the story like he
went through a wormhole wound up in the
30th century or whatever the [ __ ] meets
all these kids and tells them the
stories of his the superhero the person
who like trained him to be a hero
which is Supergirl so there they come
together you know as a variation of the
Legion of super-heroes they all looked
up to Superman but they've kind of ret
Condit for Supergirl it's really sweet
so in this episode they're they know
what happens in the future but they
can't get involved in the present
they're in the middle of a fight they
had frozen themselves under National
City because they got lost in time but
they're like if we go into hypersleep
for five thousand years we'll wake up
and fight the blight and so that's what
they were doing and then they've been
disrupted no sudden they're involved
with what's going on Supergirl right now
and they know what happens in the future
but they can't tell them and be specific
these shows love to [ __ ] around with
time so these kids from that like Saturn
girl
and and Brainiac 5 they're not familiar
with Earth at all Monell himself had
only come to earth last season and stuff
so he's telling them stories about
Earth's greatest cultures and and
they've been destroyed in the future for
the Legion of super-heroes like the
blight has taken over and art and
history has just gone out the [ __ ]
window so they make reference to the
Great's no like you know Albert Einstein
Shakespeare and Bon Jovi and so it's
it's a real throwaway joke Rael like oh
that's kind of cute like you know he
told these kids in the future Bon Jovi
was a big deal but then in the third act
when they go to fight like that the kind
of rallying like Saturn girl is trying
to convince Montel they should join the
fight even though they're supposed to
stay out of it because if they die in
the present the world dies in the future
blah blah blah but she's just like you
know what did you always tell us about
Tommy and Gina you know and and suddenly
he smiles and like I was sitting there
going Tommy and Gina oh my god they're
[ __ ] referencing Bon Jovi [ __ ]
lyrics and so when the Legion of
super-heroes goes to fight their plant
they're blasting you gotta - what we
made it just that much [ __ ] better as
they fought rain it was a really good
comeback episode nothing makes me feel
younger then me a grown man trying to
explain the plot of a thing like this
yeah because it it reminds me of like so
dad in this episode of Knight Rider his
evil twin Garth
comes back in so he's got a [ __ ]
giant truck called Goliath that's just
the strongest kid but bigger and so yeah
like it's that level of intensity and
investment it was the only place I get
away with it like because I watched that
episode this morning and I was so
[ __ ] like oh my god it was beautiful
I was crying during the episode so I
went into the bedroom my wife woke up so
she was awakened and she was like what's
the matter I was like I got to tell you
what happened on Supergirl
and I went into that much detail and you
know what she was like I just woke up
and by the time I finished her
expression just read like I can't
believe I let you stick your dick in me
she was like you know way too much you
thought about this show way too much but
yeah I don't know what a great culture
could you could you imagine growing up
in a world where like you couldn't go
that deep on something like my old man
if my old man loved like you know
[ __ ] on a [ __ ] Star Trek which I
know he didn't it wasn't his cup of tea
but if he did there would have been
nobody for him to be like oh [ __ ] man
and then in the third act there are a
million triples you know or something
like that like you would just kind of
like it'd be your thing and then slowly
you'd find a tribe you just saw somebody
with a [ __ ] bumper sticker or
something like that it was easier for us
as kids to find like-minded individuals
but it's nice to be [ __ ] 47 and
talking about Supergirl and people
aren't like arrest that man with other
adults that I know it's kind of fun yes
news yeah we could dive into you want
some news yeah so did we talk about
Runaways we did not talk about did you
finish runaways I did finish Runaways do
you go ahead where do you they ran away
they did finally what do you think I
really liked it I really do I I feel
like I feel like this shows a little bit
out of balance and that I wanted to
spend more time with the kids that I did
with the parents you know and I get that
to a certain degree like there's a
couple of those kids you know we're like
28 years old
yeah like Chase is not a [ __ ] high
school kid but you know he's the [ __ ]
dreamy good guy cuz it's you know the CW
she's got that look parry [ __ ] happening
where you know he's like you know almost
a senior in life but not a senior
citizen you know but there was enough
kids in that show that you can't work
them as hard so you've got like there's
labor restrictions you got to lean
heavily on the parents and they're
probably better actors but I'm here for
the kids like that show for me it lives
and dies with those kids
and I like kinda loved it man I dug the
[ __ ] out of that show especially for
something that has Marvel in the title
but doesn't really hey man it's [ __ ]
there's there's Captain America hey man
it's Wolvie like this deep cuts Marvel
yeah but it was enjoyable as [ __ ] I was
sad to see it and I was like no no no I
thought maybe they'd do 12 but only 10
up to say only 10 but they got a second
season right on yeah for 13 episodes
probably next year because life sucks
yeah it's gonna take a minute I guess to
put him back together
they pulled the dinosaur off to Old Lace
I was worried about that but actually
they'd a really touching scene in the
last episode where Girt has to like say
goodbye and you knew she was acting with
like a [ __ ] rubber head but the the
actress was really good man she found is
she found a place to go where I'm
watching the scene I know it's a rubber
jet [ __ ] dinosaur I know she's acting
really to like nothing and probably when
they were like cut they were all like
ahahahaha but I was crying the whole
[ __ ] time man I was like this girl
deserves an at me really really good um
yeah yeah not Duggan I think the [ __ ]
they're doing some good stuff in Marvel
TV hint hint nudge nudge wink wink
does that mean that means I want them to
give me a job oh I thought you meant you
had a job and you're like oh here's my
big Marvel dick news I have no Marvel
dick news I'm sorry alright let's dive
into just that old regular old dick you
remember that they they were making a
flash movie for a while they have been
threatening Vegas for quite some time
but now for the first time I'm more
interested than I ever was because I
liked what they did with Ezra Miller's
flash or rather I guess we should say I
like what Azra Miller did with flash and
that's a tall order because I'm a big
Grant Gustin fan I'm going up to shoot
my third episode of flash next week
so when they first announced word
Network cast as somebody else and it's
not gonna be connected to the show I was
like what a [ __ ] stupid idea but I
liked what they did yeah I thought it
could stand on it on its own
yeah they've been trying for a while
they've had like 19 directors who lined
up to me
last movie all of which decided not to
make a flash movie two of whom were were
Miller and Lord Miller and Lord who left
the flash movie to go do solo yeah
though like we'll never get fired
Oh everything is rosy who doesn't like
us we're these guys and then Seth
grahame-smith the dude who did he wrote
the Batman logo movie one of them he
also wrote that the [ __ ] Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies right yes that guy
or no Lincoln vampire hunter Gabe Logan
vampire right yet the prejudice was a
book and Lincoln vampire hunter was a
movie
he got creative different step out of
that and then a Rick from alia who did
dope yeah that's right Osama for a while
and was excited they announced in a
comic-con one year and he stood up there
with the directors of the DC Universe
and Affleck including Ben Affleck it
feels like the directors of the DC
Universe is dropping like Trump's
cabinet did because you could just start
to like pull though that I'm oh [ __ ]
it's not there that guy's nuts there
that guy's not there you took us
political ma'am so I'm just ten mil
Indian zing that's so so he left
overages so now they got the two dudes
who wrote spider-man Home Coming are
there directly they're directing John
Francis daley and Jonathan Goldstein I'm
for that man I like that that script was
really good yeah it was a really tight
script they they had this would be their
second movie they did directly so
they're gonna write and directly write
into what was the first thing they
directed the vacation reboot with Ed
Helms uh-huh and Thoris dick I didn't
say it was I didn't see it either
it it's fun that dudes crying a little
bit I don't know if it's like good tears
all those like care of Tears or just
like sad tears he's not a fan of the
vacation movie but yeah so they signed
on to write and direct flash : flash
point :
electric boogaloo
well then we know they could do
fanservice very well spider-man
homecoming was a love letter to
spider-man comics so that's good they're
doing flashpoint which is so [ __ ]
smart because it allows you to do the
most interesting flash story ever told
and incorporate the rest of the DC
Universe in a way that makes sense and
if they want to change any of their
cinematic problems thus far they can do
that with flash point if they're even
interested in going forward with a
connected cinematic universe
I don't know this all sounds [ __ ]
good yeah I mean I I suppose I would
have been a little bit more chagrined at
the fact that these two guys with a very
little directorial experience get to do
this
well the Russo brothers hadn't much
[ __ ] directorial experience before
they took Winter Soldier and made that
[ __ ] awesome I'm sure and also I'm
sure Warner Brothers is just like you
know what they're gonna cost us nothing
like this movie's gonna be expensive
why [ __ ] pay a director a big fat
salary when we can give it to somebody
who's [ __ ] hungry wants to cut their
teeth prove themselves and [ __ ] like
that
I mean it's Moneyball that's smart makes
sense but more importantly they proved
they could tell a really winning story
in that particular genre so I don't know
I think that sounds smart yeah I mean
the the the one the one thing that I
would like to see not happen anymore
though is when when female directors or
directors of color come up and people
say well they don't have an experience
they don't have enough under their belts
to do a big movie like this you get then
point to these two guys and be like well
they made a vacation movie wants yeah so
like that shouldn't that be an excuse
anymore for people not getting jobs so
so you hate while they got a director
there the gambit movie remember they
were making a gambit movie yeah the
director channing tatum still wants to
make a gambit movie and but nobody else
does this they've not lost I would like
to see that you don't think people want
to see you dude whip cards in people's
faces like how do you fight crime like
this monami 52 pickup now I run joke
it's why I did that means they'll do it
will rogue be in it as well I guess she
could be why not it's 5:10 again if it's
Fox and now it's Marvel than I think
into whatever the [ __ ] they want
everybody could be in it so they lost
their lost corporate Vince
Verbinski the guy who did the pirate
movie until the Pirates movies and Lone
Ranger and movie yeah yeah way back in
the day oh my god you're right II did
that Wow what a deep cuts pull that's
actually really good movie yeah shut off
your [ __ ] like look how smart I am i
used my useless knowledge did look at it
i can't do anything with his brain all
right so wait gore verbinski leaves they
haven't announced a new director yet no
something tells me that's just gonna get
pushed again because if this fox Disney
deal is truly happening which all
indicators say yes I'm sure Kevin fog is
like let's just put a moratorium on all
X things until I get there like they
announced that New Mutants has been
moved really many many months in other
direction yeah it was it was supposed to
be coming a lot sooner and they just
moved it whereas they moved Deadpool up
by a month or something like that but
that smells to me like and I don't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] and let me just say that
like I'm gonna I'm gonna say that out
loud as a precursor to almost everything
I say I don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
because they've been put a few news
articles this week of like Kevin Smith
says they're gonna kill the Millennium
Falcon I know
and I was like he did and and then I
click on the story I'm like oh I've like
we were [ __ ] and I'm fat man I'm
Batman
like I'm 1 and I'm like that ain't news
and then on the other hand I'm like
that's that means it's a slow news week
that's good like at the end of the day
if they're like hey man Smith said
something about a movie he's got nothing
to do with same old [ __ ] story that
means that we have not gotten bombed by
North Korea yet yes yeah so it's a good
thing and also I mean you again that is
just this is all opinion I don't have
any inside information you have it
within your power to alter the course of
the Marvel Universe why could you not
alter the course of the Star Wars
universe no the only thing the Star Wars
universe wants from me is my [ __ ] 10
or 20 bucks every time one comes ok but
that being said what was I just talking
about get derailed shifting changes
Kevin Feige doing what he wants put a
pin in it you're never making this movie
without me yadda yadda yadda I cried oh
I don't know anyway you say Elf on a
shelf no he said the x-men homage so I
think I think the the they're probably
just gonna wait until the dust settles
because he wants to play with those toys
there's a motivating factor in this deal
like don't make bone and make no bones
about it Kevin Feige wanting the x-men
back was a big part of it man like at
the end of the day we're talking about
one of their most successful [ __ ]
producers on the lot and he comes to him
and he's just like look it's just a
matter of money right it makes sense to
have these characters together right and
they're like you're right BAM so I look
hot you know oh no no I'm lost [ __ ] I
forgot what I was gonna talk about I
forgot what it was I was saying like I
don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] but we gonna
like solve cold fusion or something are
you gonna like I know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
but if you ask if you add the covalent
molecules of the [ __ ] hydrogenous and
the fuel and that's where maybe get
[ __ ] time-travel what I don't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] you guys but Nobel Prize
me [ __ ] I wish I was your
version of me
all right moving on to the next thing uh
so there's a there's also a han Solo
movie coming out in May that's right
like nineteen different directors on it
it does almost as many as the flash but
they shot it including half the dudes
we're gonna direct the flash it's true
so there was a marketing mailer that
went out today from like Bob Iger who
was explaining to all their shareholders
like what's coming up this year what's
gonna be awesome and there was a bit of
a plot synopsis for solo in this which
spoilers everything you think is going
to happen in a han Solo movie is
happening in this movie which is he
meets Chewbacca again spoilers I don't
know if you know Star Wars but he meets
Chewbacca and he hangs out with Lando
Calrissian a little bit so he meets both
of them in this movie right because
those people have been cast so we know
that there's a [ __ ] Lando Calrissian
in it but there was a little thing that
that JCR producer dug up that there's a
toy a Lego toy that got sort of teased
this week that it's a Lego Kessel run
Millennium Falcon so that means they're
gonna do the Kessel run as well oh my
god it's like Han Solo's greatest hit
you've never knew about Han Solo but we
never showed you we're gonna show you
now including his dick that is I guess
if you're gonna do it shoot the moon
right because you want to do a series of
these like ro Guan was a one-off but
they had to cuz spoilers everybody
[ __ ] dies yes sir I did
except for no hope lives
[Applause]
gets new and [ __ ] like that but yeah
[ __ ] man yeah not a lot of surprise in
that movie at least near as we can tell
or at least the [ __ ] that we know we're
gonna get we knew we were gonna get
anyway I mean you want to sit there and
be like come on but like if you're gonna
make a han Solo movie god bless you I
guess you'd have to include the Kessel
run if you're gonna do like it smells
like if he's meeting Lando maybe he's
winning the Falcon and everything's
gonna happen in this [ __ ] movie is
there anything they ever mentioned
they'll probably I bet you jabo will be
a factor yeah would have to be you think
Boba Fett they'll let him walk through
in the background or something like then
they just fall down and die I guess you
I guess it makes sense but it's like
what if the movies huge like what do
they do for the next one they're like oh
[ __ ] we spent we shot our wad delay
let's make it that Han Solo can force
project across the galaxy
alright well that's good yeah we'll have
that my favorite movie from 2014 can you
guess what it is just guess Wadley look
at Fifty Shades yes yes marks like what
can I say I like movies about desire I
don't know what was your favorite movie
my family of 2014 was John wick were you
a giant I like John wick very much it
wasn't my favorite movies a year but I
liked it very much
I remember you like that quiet movie by
the one that I will watch any [ __ ]
time it's on and I've seen John Wick's
87 times really yeah because you could
just [ __ ] turn it on whenever you
want and it's awesome and it doesn't the
dog dies and then everything else makes
sense
sorry spoilers the dog dies did you
watch the sequel I didn't watch the
sequel and I didn't love the sequel as
much I loved the first one the first one
is this pure piece of cinema awesomeness
the second one is like world building
for dummies
what do you mean world-building they
spend like 45 minutes telling them about
a backstory of the hotel oh really
but here's the thing the hotel is
getting a TV show ah stars and lions
Gator teaming up for the continental a
TV show that will take place in and
around the famed Continental Hotel where
everything is legal except for killing a
Minutemen Keanu is an executive producer
of this and will probably appear as John
week in one form or another that's cool
it's a good idea [ __ ] yeah I'm all about
that cuz I love that movie even though I
didn't love spending 19 hours in a hotel
in the sequel I will spend 22 hours as a
TV show in that [ __ ] hotel if they
just break it up into bits break it up
into bits I'm all good very nice but yes
so that's coming from stars at some
point there's still a lot of [ __ ] that
needs to get hammered down but the
director of the fit one of the director
of the film Chad's to hell ski I believe
his name is I'm probably mispronouncing
that eight different ways he's directing
the pilot and it's written by the same
dude who wrote the feature so it's in
good hands
that's they are they're getting
everything they can out of that IP is
they now call it indeed good for them
man good for Keanu to who like
understands it like people like this I'm
in done what else do you need me to do
yeah speaking of stars they have this
little television show called American
Gods did you watch any of the American
Girl gaming's American Gods I did not
yet I've failed in that respect you fail
the city yeah it is I love it so it is
bonkers in almost every way she'll can
be bonkers it goes for it at every
chance it could go for it including time
that kind of shouldn't go for it but
maybe restraint would be on your side
but whatever the [ __ ] this bison has
flaming eyes sure this is a field of
skulls why not that lady's a zombie just
kick the dudes crotch out through her
spine fine all of this is good by me but
stars and fremantle who briefs the show
yes have dismissed the to show runners
Brian fuller and Michael Greene yeah the
show Michael Greene yeah yeah who had
the greatest year of any screen
ever because he did he wrote Blade
Runner alien alien covenant Logan Murder
on the Orient Express and was running
American Gods
all in one year but those two guys were
were let go from the show the
scuttlebutt is it was over budget that
they were spending all of the money and
Fremantle was like maybe not all the
money how about like three quarters of
the money so they got their bond set off
the show they got a little Darabont
they're off the ship that they're about
nice iteration is our friend but Neil
Gaiman this all came out at tcas the
Television Critics Association like
Winterthur were all the network's parade
their wares in front of the TV critics
of the world right that Neil Gaiman is
going to come on as the showrunner of
his own show
Oh in a limited fashion Oh Oh because
that mean it means he's also doing good
omens for Amazon yeah which he's running
himself and he said listen I can come
and help on this but I can't be the
adult in the room you don't have to find
me somebody else so we still don't know
what that somebody else is yet but Neil
Gaiman will not be actually rescuing his
own show I mean when you say it like
that sounds horrible he's like I watched
it die it was lovely I'm sure he'll do
all that he possibly can but they're
going forward they are they're doing
they're doing a cheaper season to
probably which you know it happens when
you spend the moon but only get the
stars they announced that well this week
there was a photo of Tom Hardy as Eddie
Brock in the venom movie which
thankfully they told us that because it
looks like a photo of Tom Hardy period
like you know without a mask I can't
recognize him without without him being
venom it's just [ __ ] him so they've
been I guess they're shooting now and so
the the people with cameras nearby
capturing some scenes or you know from a
distance one but and I guess maybe they
finally said this is something we all
wanted to know and maybe they said it
because maybe they're gonna be shooting
outside so maybe they had to [ __ ] say
something but they've confirmed
that Tom Hollands spider-man will be in
venom yeah that's that's really really
cool I mean real minute it was smelling
like now that's so nice spider man world
that's gonna be separate but now it
feels like they worked well together
with homecoming and and so their plan
yeah and it feels like you actually need
that glue to make it work I agree I
didn't know how they were gonna [ __ ]
do it without reference to Spider Man
yeah something like that it kind of
doesn't make any sense so though we
don't we're not gonna get the symbiont
suit I'm sure symbiote well that's how
would they do it I don't know but I mean
we're not going to see the Spider Man we
see in Avengers 2 slash infinity war
does not see I mean maybe he gets it at
the end of Infinity Ward the black suit
and then that spins us into venom maybe
well I mean in in the comics it was
during the secret Wars right he went
into space all the heroes went into
space they were made to fight and then
that's where he got the symbiotic suit
which was an alien life-form
that responded to his thoughts so he
just thought of the suit and it came on
to him and he didn't have to pull on his
dopey suit and the webs we're still that
he still have his own web shooters or
the suit between the suit gave him the
webs so he separated from the suit
because it did it ever it started making
him a little crazy or no I think it's
like he would wake up places like there
was missing time for Peter Parker we'd
be like he woke up in the suit was
blowing him it was single white female
is going off [ __ ] I came just dry clean
only alien I don't want to be like this
the he eventually like got out of the
suit I can't remember the exact reason
was I think it was because he was like I
don't trust the sentient suit anymore
and then the suit had to go find
somebody else to live on and it found
Eddie Brock who's like I [ __ ] hate
Peter Parker he's another photographer
if I remember correctly
Peter was a photographer as well
competing photographer so the suit goes
onto him and he's a big muscular [ __ ]
dude and so venom was a big muscular
version of that spider-man suit so
that's all
that's very tied in with spider-man I
don't know how you do that story without
them sounds like they are but there's no
way they're doing Secret Wars and I
don't think they'll I mean if they're
shooting that venom movie now
and granted then they'll need like six
months for because there'll be a lot of
effects CG with that character Avengers
happens when man so he would have to get
a suit at the end of that version and
yep in order to have it ready for and if
they did that that's what a magical
world we live in where they're like oh
we just couldn't let it not be this so
yes it's a [ __ ] suit from outer space
just like you remember in the comics
that's that might be a little too much
to ask well here's what happens though
it's it's a it's a post-credits tag
you're so [ __ ] smart Peter Parker oh
my god like that's they they don't need
to fire [ __ ] Michael Green they just
need to bring you on and figure out how
to do things more economically you're
like just do the whole season in a tag
he goes on he hangs out with the
Guardians he's on the Milano there's a
[ __ ] box he opens the box and it's a
[ __ ] black suit this is dope and then
BOOM we just see it crawl on his hands
and then you cut out of that suit who
gave him the suit maybe it's on the
Milano on the guardianship so it wasn't
meant to be the spider-man suit but it
just I'm getting excited you just making
this up we don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
that should be the subtitle for this
guy's window [ __ ] about [ __ ]
I like your version okay and in other
news as well The Walking Dead just
switch their showrunner Scott Gimple for
a long time Scott Gimple for the last
three years for seven be Angela Angela
Kang who's the co-executive producer on
the show she I'm right and forever on
that she's been on that show since she
was a staff writer the second season why
the shake-up do you think I think it's
because Scott Gimple now the storehouse
of television information about Walking
Dead they wanted to have him oversee
everything so now he's going to oversee
this oversee fear The Walking Dead
oversee
spinoff TBD I think they're talking
about because they're trying they're
gonna do another dead show I mean I wish
it still ain't dead Wow good for them
not dead yet AMC's gonna be the all dead
Channel
but yes Angela can you say keep talking
like that it will be comic book man yeah
and I think our our last bit of news is
that we're talking about Bryan Fuller
earlier Bryan Fuller who correct me if
I'm wrong didn't he do Pushing Daisies
he did do Pushing Daisies [ __ ] loved
that show god I love that show so sad
when that show went away it was so you
want to talk about distinct unique what
a [ __ ] voice but he's done a lot he's
done a lot of [ __ ] she's done a lot
of things she did Hannibal as well
Hannibal he was on heroes Oh was he on
here yeah him with Tim Kring uh-huh and
he'd started Star Trek discovery and
then left to go do American Gods and he
left him American gods under shadowy
circumstances and now he's going to be
running the Vampire Chronicles
television show about Lestat The Vampire
Lestat oh we talked about that who's
doing who's paramount the paramount
network I think is now involved in it
the paramount network as what you
formerly spike it just dies tonight
right yeah there's somebody I don't know
who was but somebody whoever does spike
social media it's got a badass yeah
today just like pretended to be spike
the channel and just started being real
and honest and it's it's a pretty
hysterical read like at one point it's
like I gave all my employees empty gift
certificate cards for Christmas because
I suck something like that
so Spike's going away that's a huge like
15 years yeah and they're flipping the
brand and it's not like when when sci-fi
or sky 5 went to Sippy like this is a
complete [ __ ] change of brand
altogether yeah it's you like a little
spy a spike person then turn it on the
next day and suddenly be presented with
the Paramount yeah with the westerns is
that what they're doing they're doing
waco the miniseries
David correct Melissa Melissa they're
doing Yellowstone the sort of modern-day
Western with
what's-his-face Kevin Costner so that's
okay yeah like spending money to get in
the prestige business although I don't
know if anybody's gonna watch the
paramount Network and I want to get Mme
Oh what Kevin Costner looking grim at
the horizon is that what they used to
have on Spike with no mm a lot of
wrestling a lot of tattoo shows the
occasional like Saturday afternoon Hunt
for Red October a thong because why
would you not do that if you had a
network but so they're doing the Vampire
Chronicles with Anne Rice and
Christopher rice involved and they're
going to tell the long and winding story
of The Vampire Lestat who's Christopher
rice and rice is sunny does he write the
books now or something he co writes the
books with with Anne yeah really I have
read I never heard that really that came
later I wasn't like for all the famous
books we know that was like later in
life I think it's a little bit like when
Mike Bryan Herbert took over writing
doom books for Frank J Herbert that was
a thing - yeah really I didn't know that
[ __ ] I thought that only happened in the
comics like the guy who wrote Family
Circus gave it to his kids and they were
like no [ __ ] thanks but yeah I have
not read a book in 30 years and so I was
in high school and pretended to be a
goth yeah which was weird I mean it
never fit I'll just say right now it
didn't really work but I read I read the
interview the vampire the vampire lestat
but there was a third one I want to say
was about a mummy
what was it Queen of the Damned there it
is
there have been 48 different vampire
novels at this point the most recent
which involve him going to Atlantis so
maybe there's one too many vampire
novels he went underwater
Lestat goes to Atlantis which sounds
like I made that [ __ ] up and like word
jumble or something like sure put these
three words together in a row where they
make sense were there water breathers
worth was it the lost city of Atlantis I
all I know is he goes to Atlanta so I'm
assuming that it's underwater Atlantis
is not like Michigan if there's an
Atlantis
or the casino resort mantis-like we ran
out of ideas so we sent Lestat to a
casino surprise he wins yeah so so that
will be coming on screens I think next
year they're planning on well right and
so Fuller's doing that what do you thing
he just left American guards and disgust
so he got fired and he got hired right
away and that works all the time at that
level nobody stays unemployed for that
long so I got like a hockey coach if
they get fired they get picked up like a
week later by another team than the leak
Wow so there's job security and being
Bryan Fuller there is there's only but
one it's true
all right good for him man I look
forward to watching that I guess I'll
figure out what network the Paramount
what channel the paramount network is on
that's their name the Paramount network
yeah that the most boring name yeah like
I mean spike they had more [ __ ] going
for it than the paramon that worked I
mean I'm out full I think they think
people really like Paramount what can
you think of another channels got a
long-ass name that many syllables in
their name the Discovery Channel and
they did pretty well but I don't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] apparently well at least
I know what I'm getting when I got on
the Discovery Channel I'm gonna discover
some [ __ ] that's trying to have a good
night just gonna paramount some [ __ ]
yeah what's their [ __ ] slogan gonna
be we're of paramount importance but
climb on you should pitch that to a man
we're a parent with a paramount network
climb on is that it oh my god we killed
somebody sorry everybody okay don't mind
us all right man is that it for the new
night as all the news the Torah News did
we not miss anything
I think we're saving if we do we'll find
out in this next section of the show the
next section of the show ladies and
gentlemen
is everybody's favorite that's when we
turn to the audience and we start doing
Q&A yeah
as per usual we got gifts to give out to
people that ask questions that we deem
worthy and we're not really all that
judgy or anything the questions just
have to apply to both me and mark and
have to generate some good conversation
what you'll get this time around is our
good friends at the Ripley's Believe It
or Not auditorium has given us giving us
tickets to give out you'll get two
tickets to Ripley's and you'll also get
two tickets to the 40x theater here in
Los Angeles
our good friend Egon has brought 40 X
tickets for us to give away if you've
not seen a movie in a 40 X theater
please go do yourself a favor and go see
it if it snows in the movie it snows in
the theater if somebody burns rubber in
the movie you smell that burnt rubber
sooner or later like they're gonna take
a Seth Rogen movie and you will smell
weed in the theater the chair moves
around man it's a [ __ ] ride and a
half it's awesome so we got tickets for
they've got a theater here at LA Live is
that word right so you can go see a
movie there and stuff and we thank the
40x folks for those tickets ok yes give
it up for 40 now four sets in Ripley's
tickets in 540 XT is that right okay so
somebody's going without a Ripley all
right fair enough but still okay we JC
you got a microphone you ready to go BAM
let's do it we you tweeted me last week
said like I'm with a guy who wants to
ask a question I did that was me and it
was my friend Robert and I'm sorry I
said my new friend because I knew his
name
and his name is Robert and he's a great
all right so yes we met here so you guys
are friends since the nighttime crowd
approves very low bar all right so
you're Robert yes I'm Robert hello every
man I am great he was away for you last
week dude she was like you gotta let him
ask the first question so yeah let you
ask the first question okay well I'm
gonna cheat a little bit because this
question I've wanted to a since November
and it's just for Kevin but I have one
for both of you so it's two questions
really okay but the November question
you mentioned before in the podcast how
joke off on and off about I don't know
who listens who doesn't but Chris
Hemsworth gave a Vanity Fair interview
where he talked about the thor ragnarok
movie mm everyone loves the new tone he
credits you for the new tone and Thor
yeah exact quote is hearing someone like
Smith who represents the fanboy world
was such a kick out kick in the ass to
change gears we sort of had nothing to
lose people didn't expect what we did
with it this time around just want to
get your thoughts on that quote we I
loved it
I want more Avengers to say nice things
about me
ah we talked about it on the show is it
a big deal when it happened I was like
oh my [ __ ] god Chris Hemsworth knows
my name but I was very it was very cool
but also weeps at they're gone
because he talked about me being
critical about the Thor movies and I
honestly couldn't remember any time
maybe those were the ones I was least
effusive about where I was like man they
should let him be funny like he is in
the Avengers but for whatever reason but
he went into his bosses and he was like
the guy that made tusks said we should
do this and they [ __ ] listened so it
was nice but I don't think I deserve
that much but it felt [ __ ] cool just
that he knew my name and then he'd heard
the podcast and [ __ ] like that I think
that's kind of sweet I had another
moment like that this week when Chris
Evans tweeted there was a photo of Paul
Ryan on Martin Luther King Day staring
at a bust of Martin Luther King and he
wrote some you know [ __ ] stuff about
serious stuff about his Martin Luther
King Day and reflection and blah blah
blah and so
Chris Evans Captain America himself
would retweeted that and his comment was
like something I can't remember the
exact thing but something the effect of
like it he's it looks like he's he's
looking at a magic guy trying to see the
sailboat and so a bunch of people
forward it to me to be like [ __ ]
Chris Evans just made a Mallrats
reference man and so you know I did I
looked at I was like oh my god he legit
made a Mallrats reference and so i
retweeted him and with a quote from from
avenger said i understood that reference
that's awesome so that's two Avengers I
got two Avengers so far know my name or
work or something like that it's very
nice it felt very cool but it didn't
come with any like free tickets or
anything they didn't even ask me to go
to the premiere I don't think but it was
it was nice to read about like yeah he
was helpful we don't want him near us
but he was helpful that we have fans
everywhere in the podcast but anyway I
had a question for both of you and this
was you know we love the film we love
films we're all film fans here hear a
lot about films some films get made
don't get made
the directors go in and out of projects
some movies don't get me for whatever
reason I wanted to know any movie for
both of you that didn't get made that
you're really disappointed by it like
some examples would be Tim Burton's
Batman 3 or Richard Donner's unfinished
Superman sequels that he would love to
make what franchise or movies did you
want to see take off but maybe didn't
for whatever reason I just talked a lot
you can start to talk now yes we talked
about we did just talk about doing yeah
we talked about the Herbert passing it
on dune is one of my favorite books of
all time my favorite movies of all time
that being said I'm fascinated by what
Alejandro Jodorowsky's dune would have
looked like and there's an amazing
documentary that it's just called Yoda
or skis dune which you should look at
but it's it's examining a thing that I
already love to the prism of somebody
else's work that I'm a little familiar
with but I hadn't known
much until I saw that movie and the
thought exercise of taking something
that I know exists but trying to imagine
what it would have been like in someone
else's hands I would have liked to have
seen that do I think that dude could
have been amazing yeah I mean there's
now you're gonna get Denny Villeneuve's
dude I'm gonna get did evil news to him
I also would not have minded seeing
Terry Gilliam's Harry Potter I think he
was that a thing he was in the running I
think for the third observer Prisoner of
Azkaban and his whole his one of his big
lobbying points was nobody quite knows
what it's like to be in a British
boarding school than somebody who's been
in a British boarding school
but I think that the duty does Time
Bandits doing Harry Potter would have
been phenomenal
that said Alfonso Krones Harry Potter is
probably the best of the three and I'm
glad I got that one but in the
serendipity like the the pathless taken
that that's another one that I think
would have been fascinating to see
buckaroo banzai versed the world's crime
League as always sad that never never
happened and so sad that like when MGM
called a couple years back and said hey
my agent called actually he said do you
know anything about buckaroo banzai I
said [ __ ] yeah man I was one of my
favorite movies made me want to be a
writer I had the poster up in my room
and [ __ ] because MGM has property they
want to take it out into the world turn
into a series do you want to go talk to
him about it and I said I've talked to
anybody about buckaroo banzai so I went
into MGM and you know they were coming
off of first season of Fargo had done
very very well so they were interested
in taking stuff from their library and
turning it into TV shows so I they said
well you know we love buckaroo banzai
thank you what would you do you know if
you were involved and I said oh I would
do the movie has season 1 of the TV show
and then season 2 would be the promised
world's crime league and they were like
what would you do for season 3 I said we
I don't know go to space and so they
were like all right you're the guy and
so we went out and pitched at a bunch of
places and we pitched it to like every
place you call the usual suspects and at
the end of the day BBC America and
Amazon wanted the most Amazon wound up
offering more and so it went there for a
minute like it looked like I was gonna
be able to see that sequel because I was
gonna be involved in that sequel problem
was the guys who created it Earl McGraw
and it was the writer and WD Richter the
director were not involved in the
process at all so we wanted to bring him
in but they were left out of it and they
weren't being financially remunerated so
there was this weird moment of like I
wanted to see the sequel to buckaroo
banzai since I was a [ __ ] kid and the
power is literally in your hands to make
that [ __ ] sequel like you don't even
have to wait anymore man it falls into
your indie ethos [ __ ] waiting for
somebody to pick you you have pictures
up and you're gonna [ __ ] make that
sequel that you've always wanted to see
and then I thought about like well what
if somebody gets clerks years from now
and they're gonna turn it into a series
and I'm like oh I'd love to come [ __ ]
play and they're like we're good like
that would break my [ __ ] heart and
[ __ ] so I I stayed involved and and for
a minute and then all of a sudden I
dropped out like it was weird it was a
weird crisis of conscience where I
wanted something really badly but it's a
and also it would have been nice to have
like a [ __ ] show to [ __ ] around with
and do what you want but at the same
time like I didn't wanted that I didn't
want it that bad not bad enough to
[ __ ] ice those dudes out so I dropped
out and kind of walked away from it so I
can't [ __ ] about not seeing the thing
or they oh man they didn't do it because
I could have done it but the I don't
know conscience went out at the end of
the day so hopefully somebody will do it
one day because I title alone captured
my imagination it was so comic book at a
time when that was very sparse like
nowadays throw rock and something
somebody's super and somebody's parents
have [ __ ] died and they need
vengeance and they're gonna put on a
coat and mask and [ __ ] like that
but back then it was few and far between
you know within the world and cinema
world particularly so any reference felt
like water in the desert and so that
movie just the title it's all we ever
had captured my imagination and for one
brief shining moment I was gonna be able
to [ __ ] tell the story but somebody
else would get to it eventually I think
that's more answer than you wanted I'm
sorry give it up Fermi gets tickets all
right take us someplace else JC better
go there man hello hello how are you
excellent first time here first time
seeing you have really excited hey
before I before I ask my question my
wife actually can't be here cuz my son's
sick but she bought me tickets because
it was my birthday last week and she
knows how much I wanted to see you
because I've always wanted to tell you
at a time in my life where I really
didn't know what I wanted to do
I saw clerks and I went that's what I
want to do and I went to film school
graduated from Cal State Long Beach with
a film degree it was literally because
of clerks and I just wanted to say at a
time when just the Internet and the
world is such negativity it's like it's
so inspiring to have you who I feel is
like kind of like a beacon of like
inspiration and positivity and I just
want you to know that I appreciate you
we all appreciate you and it's just I
just really love who you are and what
you do and I find there's probably a
million of others of just like me and
it's like I I was here for two minutes I
was here for two minutes and I got to
know this guy
in this guy and this guy you know it's
like it's crazy I'm texting my wife I'm
I already made friends it's just all
five gosh well it's it's
that's and so it's just and it's all
because we all share our love for what
you do and who you are so it's just it's
cool that that means the world man thank
you so much no it's I'm honored just to
be able to look you in the eye and say
that to you I've wanted to say it since
I was 18 years old so it's crazy that
that means that honestly like I don't
just say that lightly that does
absolutely mean the world
it means way more that it's not a
statement that ends with and it never
worked out so I'm gonna kill you with
this Bob no it's it's weird it's weird
in that you have a moment like so many
people are inspired by people and it's
just it's there like a mythical person
that they'll never know and so it's like
it's awesome that I'm like I get to tell
the guy that kind of steered me like in
the face like you moved me in a
direction when nothing else would and
it's crazy I did that to Richard
Linklater he was the guy I know it I do
tell that story and I always laugh at
Mike Kevin tells my story but it's just
someone else it's literally the same
story it's nice you're gonna have to do
the show without us cuz we're gonna go
in the back and [ __ ] now clearly it's
this man gets me man it's funny it's
funny it's because my wife always jokes
and like she's saying I'm fearing you
going to this thing but like I'm gonna
let you have this but you know and then
I go oh babe I don't want to [ __ ] him I
just want to be his friend but I will
[ __ ] but I tell her if you don't any
soul for every time I heard that in my
life I don't want to [ __ ] you I just
want to be your it's true but I tell her
babe I'll be his touch it I'll be at
such a good friend I'll treat him I'll
treat him so good so okay either way
I'll ask my questions so Kevin Feige
said as I believe the Avengers lineup
will not be the same in phase 3 as it is
in phase 2 so my question is who are
they going to kill and if they do kill
them how and will they be replaced
I didn't say anything move on if so who
and if so how
yeah well it's how because let's say if
it's Captain America you know are they
gonna replace him with Falcon is it
gonna be Bucky is someone gonna take on
the mantle of Captain America yes or are
they just gonna kill arrows and no one's
gonna pick up the bow no well yeah I
honestly if Hawkeye goes down I doubt
they're gonna rush to refill that this
exactly but I don't he's the obvious one
I mean [ __ ] we all thought he was gonna
die in age of Ultron like it looked like
they were leading up to that and then
they're like now we like being around
Jeremy Renner so you told us where to
buy our houses that's deep cuts so I
think if you playing Moneyball and you
don't have to because now Disney owns
Marvel but at the end of the day the
most expensive person in their world is
Robert Downey jr. if he's whatever he's
getting paid but for my amount for my
opinion it's not enough he is the very
strong spine upon which all of that
universe rests but maybe he's gotten to
a point where he's like priced out
you're not talking about a guy who makes
20 million a movie anymore he's not
gonna about a guy who makes all the
money
right like they're like what do you want
to be in it and he's like all of it and
they're like okay right so I think
financially speaking if you were like
you know these movies are only gonna go
on and get bigger and over you know
that's a cord you can cut it's also a
very emotional cord to cut because the
entire universe hangs on Tony Stark Iron
Man the Marvel Universe for the in the
real world hangs on the spine of Robert
Downey jr. that performance in Iron Man
launched an entire series of movies that
were credible and plausible and
connected to him always kind of coming
back
his character who better to throw under
the [ __ ] Thanos bus than that and if
you look at that first trailer they put
up its a lot of Tony out of the outfit
looking scared so I for my money I think
they're gonna wind up killing Tony Stark
do you think maybe they'll even mend the
relationship between Captain America I
would have to because if in his death it
seems like they come together and they
mend what what's broken to believe they
absolutely have to I think like Tim
what's his name a Hemsworth has been in
the news lately talking about my deal is
up officially right I've now contractual
all the contractual obligations I had to
Marvel are finished but I'd do it again
I'd keep going if they wanted to do
another which seems like a soft
indication that his character is not
going to die in the in the if it New
Avengers movies but a [ __ ] I bet I
won't say my life but I'll bet like my
[ __ ] fortune everything I've got in
this world on the fact that Loki dies in
those movies they're building they've
been building that Ark it seems like
since the beginning and the last Thor
movie you know he's actually taking the
kind of turn and become more good than
bad and there he is working with his
brother and [ __ ] like that and yes they
revealed that he stole the cube and I
guess that's what's gonna bring the
Thanos into their [ __ ] trajectory but
I think that gives him a chance he also
knows that oh s--- remember like he was
the wife Anna sent him the earth with
the Chitauri army feels like they're
building him up to be able to sacrifice
himself for his brother so he dies a
hero and I think we've seen like a
preview of it in Thor you know they
showed Matt Damon Loki dying and [ __ ]
like and that's supposed to be a
reference to other [ __ ] and stuff but I
I think it's I do think they're gonna
kill him off that would be my bet cold
hard money on that what about you who
they got killed uh I think I think
Hawkeye should die probably won't die I
guess or something you have like with
with with Black Widow you have the
character who is incredibly overpowered
for the situation yeah and if you're
dealing with [ __ ] gods in the cosmos
or dude who shoots an arrow
or a lady who's got two little pistols
can't do a whole hill of beans in that
particular fight so but I don't think
you're gonna kill scarlet I don't think
you're gonna kill Scarlett Johansson
somebody's got to drive the ship
somebody's gonna [ __ ]
so between Hawkeye and black widow
somebody there's a somebody without meta
powers or super powers that can be
useful in the fight and not just be like
what are we gonna do I think I think
rather I think they might kill Kat I
think that the idea like Captain
America's been a soldier for as long as
he's been alive a soldier comes to grips
with the fact that your job in many
instances is to die you're being paid to
die you're being recruited to die you're
on the frontlines if you're a marine
then your job is to soak up well it's on
a beach somewhere I think that Steve
Rogers would be okay with that result to
his life if he died in a line of duty if
he died for a reason I think that his
heroic death is the Coulson writ large
it's a good death it's a good day I also
think were in me I would kill Drax also
I am a [ __ ] nightmare of a person I'm
a classroom man I know that but if if
Drax has it in for [ __ ] Thanos it's
establishing Guardians one's true who
knows him as well as anybody does if
they don't have his chance he'll have
his chance and he will have his chance
it'll be a noble Pyrrhic death but
there's there's a way in which that is
also the beating heart in a way of the
Guardians if Drax goes it's gonna be
intense
stuff because then they go into a
Guardians 3 which James Gunn just said
is gonna be 2020 Guardians 3 and he's
also confirmed somebody asked on Twitter
like you know you're gonna bring Ianto
back and he was like no not at all he's
like that death has to mean something
and as long as I'm involved in these
movies yondu will never come back so if
that's the case then they'd be starting
Guardians 3 without yondu and without
[ __ ] Drax but that's a good pull man
you're right it's true I forgot about
he's got a thing for Thanos is that in
both movies or just the first movie
I think it's the first movie I think
it's the first moment you think they
kill that many people in the first movie
yeah I think it'd be smart man cuz if
you went to that movie in there like we
killed [ __ ] Iron Man [ __ ] you'd be
like I gotta know who dies next you know
in in the two-parter at all then you you
leave the first part with everything is
worse as a can possibie the the the
lowest part of that particular arc and
that's [ __ ] you know Luke Skywalker
with his new Bionic hands staring over
the stars wondering why the [ __ ] on so
low is like where the death of Tony
Stark or the another Tony Stark and or
Captain America I gotta be honest I look
forward to it not because like I want to
see him die I love that character and I
could watch Robert Downey jr. do
anything including my wife but but I but
at the same time ago stand here the
whole time yeah I'm like [ __ ] he's
charming but I do look forward to I like
the story they've been telling for 10
years I like his whole entire character
arc and I think it wouldn't feel cheap
by any stretch of the imagination
if he dies in battle with fan OHS I
think that'd be strong [ __ ]
storytelling yeah as long as they don't
blast him out into space and then he
forced flies back there sometimes I'm
just hoping that in one of these movies
Coulson [ __ ] comes back because that
is still the last shoe that's never
dropped is the fact that Coulson is
alive and well somewhere and the
Avengers don't know yeah that's well
Joss when he was in charge said that
wasn't the case he was like Coulson's
did Coulson is dead in my world that's
his death has to mean something
everybody seems to say that like the
death has to mean say except that Joslin
brought him back for agents of shield
for four years it was that Joss or his
brother that was jealous hmm so so that
he should see the Avengers again at some
point the remember that thing that
galvanized us into action my death
psych
so he should be a bad guy yeah like fan
OHS is like here's my ultimate weapon
and [ __ ] he comes out he's like I'm
alive you pricks four years of a TV show
without your asses they never really did
have any Avengers crossovers on this
show today I mean Nick Fury showed up
early on very early on
yeah and there's a bunch of like Easter
eggs [ __ ] and Haley we have some
Chitauri tech that we got to deal with
but beyond that now all right that was
good question man you get the tickets
give it up for me I'm gonna take us and
thank you so much man's incredibly
[ __ ] sweet go home tell my wife this
is how you have to talk to me from now
on
where we going JC I'm sorry I was really
laughing at the iron cook that you just
mentioned earlier letting iron men bang
your girlfriend hello my name is Jeffrey
Clarke I'm wearing a justice Lords ring
because evil Superman is best Superman I
have two quick questions they're really
quick you start every conversation like
that yes I do evil Superman I want to
ask two quick questions the first one is
I go to Cal State LA and I'm trying to
run a student-run talk show no with no
help we're crowdfunding it and I would
love to have you two as guests on our
show it's running from March to July
that would be the best thing in the
universe for our show especially since
we have no support we're doing it on our
own and secondly since we're on the
subject of Black Panther and all these
great superhero movies coming out which
superhero of color and female superhero
would you love to get their own movie
for me it would be static shock and
Shera because why not which superhero
first I'll answer the first question of
being on your show no no yes happy -
happy - sweet you as we change emails
like yeah I'll show up I guess if you
drive I'll go where is it where do you
go we're shooting it at Cal State Los
Angeles real crowd funding for the the
camera materials now we're gonna race
we're gonna try to raise $20,000 so we
can put this on public access television
which I've already paid for so once we
shoot it it'll go on television and
we'll be fine
we're just trying to get our guests in
order amazing people like you and other
people who are working so we can prove
that we're
badasses and we can get jobs wait you
raised $20,000 no we're about to we're
gonna right now I'm gonna [ __ ] sweet
cash hero of color I'd like to see get
their own movie all right you know
twofer storm whoo there is no reason on
God's green earth why there is not a
storm movie one of the most powerful
characters in them all the universe the
leader the x-men at one point just
badass all around I think there's a
world in which you could spin storm out
of a black panther I have no idea if
Aurora is in Black Panther but out of
that world I can see a path you can
connect the dots to get to Oro Munro
well use the earlier idea they meet him
post-credits oh I see the range down in
Africa see that that is that is my
answer
well I mean traditionally has better
carat well yes he is a character of
color but they've made him more a
character of color recently or something
to use the term John Jones the Martian
Manhunter yeah one of my favorite
characters of all time traditionally
like the John Jones persona was a white
guy with Supergirl they changed it and
and the the backstory they did for I
mean he's Hank and Shaw which as we all
know becomes the evil Superman but he
kind of reclaimed the identity it's very
convoluted but the idea of the alien
african-american in the alien persona
that they've touched on a little bit in
that show but you could go way deeper
with and I just loved that character I
mean I with all due respect to David
Goyer he gave some interview once where
he was just like talking about these DC
movies he's like we'll never do the
Martian Manhunter that's just stupid and
I'm like no man like that's a really
beautiful character you're talking about
a refugee somebody who's just [ __ ]
stuck on this planet just like Superman
no just doesn't happen to look golden
like Superman and there's some [ __ ]
story some clever story but better
writer than I could come up with to be
told there you know it's one thing to
come to earth look like Superman
everything [ __ ] works out for you if
you look like the Martian Manhunter it's
a lot tougher so I would do that with
the with the current spin that they're
using the Supergirl yeah thank you so
much it means a lot to me and my that
was gonna be my go-to answer Jon Stewart
but I felt that was too like well they
got one guy don't they
I kind of I kind of like to go in the
other way alright thank that was great
question man you get the tickets
[Applause]
pleasure all right where we going next
JC can't he doesn't see you hole how are
you I'm doing well are you guys doing
so good what's your name my name is Matt
give it up for Matt Matt and we'll give
it up for my voice though I mean I clerk
so I'll answer anything so so first off
kind of like this guy I mean I'm not
gonna blow you as hard but so back in
March I had a surgery and I kept
watching fat man on Batman was lined up
in bed for six weeks and there was
something that you said about just you
know if you don't agree with something
if you don't like content go make your
own and that really stuck with me and
you guys really just between the both of
you you guys really inspired me to kind
of just write my own comic and it's
really just spun from the arrowverse and
Slade Wilson because I really loved Manu
Bennett's interpretation of Deathstroke
and it's just something for me that I
want to see I don't care if it gets
picked up or anything like that I have a
couple friends who are like this sounds
awesome I want to draw for it and so
thank you cuz that's awesome it's given
me something that really do so thank you
[Applause]
maybe and then the question that I have
for you is in the same vein of the arrow
verse let's say Berlanti called you up
and was like hey next year we want you
to do the four-part crossover what's the
story you do between the both of you
because I think both of you guys would
be fantastic and would it be Rock of
Ages and if so how do you get around the
dark side of it all yeah of course if
they gave me any carte blanche I would
try to do Rock of Ages but you couldn't
really do it without the the real
Justice League it would be so compromise
I would go for I mean you can't do the
real crisis on Infinite Earths but they
do have a multiverse in that show like
super girl exists in a different
universe than flash and and arrow so you
could the worlds are colliding you know
like the multiverse story the classic
crisis on Infinite Earths multiverse
story that would cover a week of
programming and stuff I would go for
that you I like of everything that's the
one that's taking a lot out of it Jill
o'clock I would kill Oliver Queen I
would make it the death of Oliver Queen
that's two monster established sir
Ashton answered counselor move on I
think that that arrow is probably
starting to run its course and there was
a world in which in a year two years
maybe you come to the end of arrow if
you're going to do that then [ __ ] do
it and if you're gonna do it and make it
count make it big make it real and make
the death of Oliver Queen your four part
crossover like what happens how who did
it how if I know who did it the fallout
from it all of that what happens though
after that does arrow keep going or is
the show end maybe that's your giant
season finale as opposed to it sweeps
event where you do four episodes that
ends the season and it ends with the
death of Oliver Queen
you took us down ma'am hey good answer
good answer man he wins the tickets give
him the tickets well done all right man
where we going next JC hi there
this question would have been more
relevant probably like three years ago a
very prominent director I can't remember
who said it but said superhero movies
will go the way of the Western
considering everything has a bell Lucas
or Spielberg I think I want so Spielberg
yeah okay so I was right so anyway
England rector of ready player one what
a difference three years make oh yeah do
you think superhero movies will go the
way the Western and if so why or why not
III don't think so the the Western I
don't I don't know why the Western
stopped maybe people were just like oh
I've seen this before so I guess there
could be a saturation point with her
Oaks like super heroics but at the end
of the day that's the stuff that movies
are made of like you know there's a
problem only this person can solve that
problem this whole world's against this
person this person has triumphed like
you can break that down into every movie
almost doesn't have to be that's almost
the plot of It's a Wonderful Life as
well but it's also the plot of Batman
too so you can those stories stories
about people overcoming adversity and
winning the day good triumphing evil
there will never be a lack of interest
in that and the westerns worked off of
those principles as well but you know I
just I can't I can't imagine that a
certain point people are like I'm done
with the superhero movie it just feels
like it's kind of here to stay for no
other reason honestly than like morality
tales have been with us since we've been
talking to one another and and they're
all kind of morality tales at the end of
the day with this listen the lesson is
the same over and over again it's better
to be good than to be bad you know so I
don't think they're going anywhere you
yeah I think westerns
Westen's went away because they stopped
being cheap you know I mean westerns was
the dominant genre for a while because
all you needed was [ __ ] dudes and
hats we had hats a couple horses
we got the horses and we got wide-open
[ __ ] land and California in the 40s
and 50s was half as developed as it is
now so you can shoot a [ __ ] Western
for almost nothing after a while it got
more expensive and then it began like
wow geez we've seen like eight [ __ ]
hundred westerns how many new Western
stories are there not that many we still
see them because there's the the
fetishization of the Western the dream
of what the westerns symbolize it's just
a part of our cinematic heritage it is
and there's there's a little bit of a
sense of the the the Wayback Machine
lore of looking into the past and
remembering when it was easier and
simpler in a way I think superhero
movies right now speak to our cultural
desire to be special in a way where
westerns spoke to our desire to be free
in a way and I think that as long as
people want to be super as long as
people want that aspiration to live up
to will see superhero movies the cost
does not seem to be prohibitive there's
all these things cost to earn a million
dollars and it doesn't matter will they
go away no I think there is a decreasing
number of people who decide they want to
launch into a universe because that's
hard work as DC I'm sure can attest to
launching universe the whole cloth but I
think that I mean God Marvel is not
gonna start making them like they have
no interest in stopping to make them it
doesn't make sense to stop making them
same way we're gonna see a Star Wars
movie every year for the rest of my life
good better and different we're gonna
see it because that's the way this
industry is built that's the engine that
makes all of this drive so while I well
will we see three Marvel movies and one
[ __ ] DC movie and some offshoot Fox
Columbia movie in the same calendar year
every year probably not but are we gonna
see a Marvel movie every year yeah yeah
well we see a DC movie every other year
we should if they can figure it out
but like as a genre I don't see it going
the way the Western at least not for
another 10 15 20 30 years it's weird we
always reference the Western there were
a lot of people do in reference to these
flicks but it's a bad parallel the
Western was popular because it was
[ __ ] inexpensive these movies have
never been inexpensive like that's just
part of the gamble is like there's a lot
of money involved but it's it's they
define tentpole cinema cinema now you
spend a [ __ ] ton of money and you can
make a [ __ ] ton of money particularly if
you're building a universe
yeah it's you're right I think I think
just like Star Wars and cancer superhero
movies will be with us forever I mean
the thing that I wish would happen is
that Studios would not give up the
middle ground as they seem to have like
you have three million-dollar movies and
you have three hundred million dollar
movies but the 40 million dollar studio
movie seems to have disappeared what
used to be the adult thriller or the
romantic comedy or that's it it's just
gone I mean it's it's blum house or it's
Marvel and there's a world in which
they're storytellers you don't get to
tell mature stories TV has taken over
that particular zone but I wish that
that Hollywood would remember that
there's a variety of stories you can
tell and an audience for almost
everything if you make it right yeah
Hollywood doesn't need to amen Hollywood
doesn't need to remember like Netflix
does they they'll they make one of
everything they do and and yeah but and
now they're getting into the big budget
game as well I mean bright cost them
almost a hundred million dollars and
they're making another one of those how
long do you think before they make a big
move like what could they guess there's
really nothing to buy I mean they bought
the Mark Millar's that's right they
bought Melara million two million
dollars they just lock stock and barrel
so yeah we're gonna see comic [ __ ] on
there soon enough Warner Brothers will
never let go of DC right no there's no
need you know and Marvel Disney will
never let go of Marvel so those two are
spoken for for a long time
I think Sony bought a valiant
last year maybe to start a valiant verse
why people who like valiant Jack
[ __ ] alright
you a man you won the tickets give it up
firm we were out of tickets but we can
only take like three more questions
ticket list questions you won't want a
prize but you could we'll start some
conversation we do have a bet oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] me you will win a prize yes I do it
for free though
go ahead what's your name Alfonzo give
it up for Alfonzo take us there sir what
do you want to know all right first and
foremost all your movies relate to me in
such a way it's just thank you so much
for speaking my voice sorry swallow Mike
man I hear that every [ __ ] week Don
small [ __ ] my clerks I've been in
retail my whole life mall rats always
been a comic book geek I'm part of this
nerd world order hands down
jaysene Amy I mean I love lesbians
[Laughter]
sure
Jersey girl I've been a single father
and and I've overcome so much with that
and my kids are in a really good place
because of it but my questions
you know enough stroking it but my
question first of all we're gonna start
with Mark because we always start with
Kevin I love you to death Kevin but I
want to start with Mark because Mark
you're amazing okay I've listened to
every single episode of fat man of
Batman the one thing I've never heard is
what is your favorite Kevin Smith movie
and then my second part of that of
course I want to include Kevin here have
you read any of his reviews of your
movies
[Applause]
and what did you think to the best of my
knowledge I've never reviewed one of
your movies I I don't think you have
because it would have come up by now
well Harry carb is talking about
something and I would have been like Oh
mark is it slow-moving do you wish I
move the camera more in this
conversation my my favorite eye I have
yet to hold forth on what my favorite
Kevin Smith movie is it's a little bit
like choosing your favorite grandchild
do you see yourself as the grandchildren
father of my movies in the like or or
the favorite nephew in a way all right
he's my friend his movies are his
children and I'm like the honorary uncle
oh right it would be like picking like
war or the analogy is like if the movies
are my kids if I had more than one kid
like I got one kid I got Harley so it's
easy for me like oh I like his kid but
if I had three kids I was like which one
do you like the most which one do you
want the most because I'll sell it to
you I mean I think that that Dogma is
about a lot more than it seems to be
about in a way Dogma is is incisive into
religion in a way that most movies about
religion aren't and there's a giant
[ __ ] [ __ ] monster in the middle of it
it is the most maybe not counting strike
back but the most John removi I think
that he's made yeah and and so I dig it
real hard I think chasing amy is also
fantastic incredibly well done
my heart belongs to Metatron mm-hmm
well we just passed the anniversary I
guess was on what Sunday Alan Rickman
passed away two years ago already he's
been gone for two years man such an
amazing [ __ ] talent and such like the
glue in pop culture for his entire
acting career once he started acting
that was it he was everywhere and like
when I put up a picture on Twitter the
other day somebody like people are
dropping lines from Dogma of course they
were dropping lines more naturally from
all the Harry Potter movies from die
hard but somebody rocked me with a
Quigley down under reference Wow Wow
that made me go watch Quigley down under
gank so I was like [ __ ] Rickman was in
that Tom Selleck and it would have been
a movie like I just counted my whole
life because I'm like Tom Selleck
[ __ ] quickly down under but it's got
Rickman and it's [ __ ] good fairly
watchable movie man Tom Selleck you see
my mom's right he is sexy almost Indiana
Jones I remember that but but for a
scheduling hiccup he would have been
your Indiana Jones
he was the first choice and then they
were like who's your second choice till
igano han Solo
the carpenter a great question you
woulda had this from encore visual
effects the people that make the special
effects for Supergirl for flash Armand
who was on fat man on Batman recently
it's a great listen
Armand Kevorkian we talked about special
effects and stuff he brought over a bag
of hats and whatnot this is one that's
got from last season the crossover
Justice Society of America there you go
my friend well done yeah oh my god happy
alright JC where we going next to turn
in the answer into a question if del
Toro had made his version of The Hobbit
based on shape of water with the dragon
have been [ __ ]
I think you've hit on the most
interesting version of smile we could
have seen my election like bad he's like
this is my treasure that is gold on my
entire body except for these notes that
definitely wins a [ __ ] something but
do you have a question if I just want to
own the room like you do with the return
of the anthology series is there room
for like an astro city type show what a
good [ __ ] call
hey I'm not in charge of the business
but I say yes but Astro City is a good
[ __ ] poll did you used to read I said
I read I was I wasn't a devotee of it
but from what I read I loved it was Kurt
Busiek right who sake the guy that did
Marvel's yeah he wrote that book didn't
eat it Avengers as well but he was the
one that created Astro city yeah that's
I would totally watch the show I imagine
it's pricey right because you're talking
about a lot of superpowers and stuff
very true the moment they give me and
put me in charge of something where I
get to make decisions like that I'm
gonna be like Astro city but for now our
idea yeah this guy was not here for this
but that's that does that answer the
question yeah but I mean you had a you
you could have stopped it not the
question so awesome give it up for him
[Applause]
where we go - hi
my name is Alina haha hey I just want to
say a quick shout out to all the girls
in the room because there's very few of
us I've noticed so shout out to us I
don't know if anybody else's nobody - it
well that was a bunch of dudes that
applause just hearing the ladies put
your hands together how many not as many
yeah it's not fifty-fifty but it's not
bad yeah and so I'm actually gonna
forfeit my question because my question
one is wasn't as good as his question so
I'm gonna hand it over to him oh my god
we just saw the generous feminine spirit
at work she's like I want to say
something here's a microphone for a man
what was your question you know what you
asking them we'll let him ask this
question go ahead so I'm a huge fan of
women obviously in superhero movies so
my question is
besides the generic like black widow or
whomever who would you guys see who
would you want to see in the next you
know Marvel or DC movie
Zatanna but not not like all the [ __ ]
fishnets like the idea of a woman who
comes from like a powerful father who
died tragically trying to save the world
and stuff like that she incorporates
well into Gotham City she knows [ __ ]
Bruce Wayne and Batman but you get to
tell you know the mystical side of
things has DCEO I mean Marvel's got you
know their sorcerer supreme and they've
already kind of touched on that world it
would be interesting to see DC had in
that direction it looked like she was
gonna be involved in Justice League dark
right the one that del Toro was gonna
make had Swamp Thing in it and John
Constantine and Deadman and and and who
the demon and the demon Etrigan and and
I think that Ana was supposed to be in
it as well but I think you could do a
total standalone Zatanna movie what
about you
uh I think I would like to see a death
the high cost of living
oh yeah [ __ ] yes god yes
God why haven't they done that yeah I
mean I think the Sandman stuff is still
wrapped up in where the [ __ ] it's
wrapped up in I'm not entirely sure it
was so good
but yeah I mean death is a phenomenal
character Neil Gaiman's version of death
is fantastic I would also like to see
she-hulk yeah I think you could have a
lot of fun with the she-hulk movie I
think that you know law meets cruiser
meets
[ __ ] yeah it's a comedy waiting to
happen with giant things smashing never
give up your voice for a man hey my name
is Ishmael so it's kind of weird he'd
said the same thing it's kind of the
same thing that he quirks inspired me
same gist but I hadn't met you about
three years ago and you had asked me
like what I was doing in my life and I
was like oh I'm just working like retail
and it really I'm kind of doing data in
retail yeah spec was it fun I was like
no I hate like whatever
so like since that point since like
later I've gotten a bachelor's in film
at a UC
so usually thank you for inspiring me to
keep going cuz I was just like I hate it
and yeah and thank you always scared
when somebody gets up to tell stories
like that years ago I met yeah
and it has someone think about for you
uh since you guys don't spark as I love
it every day I was into every day at my
new job
I started my own podcast and in the most
fun I've had
it's called what's expected it's on the
iTunes podcast it's on all of it you
guys want to do it also real quick I
don't think for calling out billboards
on your Twitter I like that you're one
of the few writers who just call it [ __ ]
out thank you is it troublesome movie it
is and three billboards and having
Zuri did you talk about it I Twitter
side I went on the Twitter's and then
the Guardian in the UK asked me to write
a piece about basically that the Twitter
rant the idea that Sam Rockwell is a
phenomenal actor by all means the movie
is populated with phenomenal actors but
there is a level of disingenuous diss
ingenuity dis ingenuity disingenuous 'no
switch that movie treats rural america
in regards to race and the fact that it
was written and directed by a member of
the british kingdom some fashion perhaps
I want to say he's Irish could be
Scottish so I'm [ __ ] about Martin
McDonagh I don't mean to but he is by
any lights an outsider and does not
understand the the textures of how race
works in America and he was unwilling to
interrogate his own view of a particular
character Sam Rockwell's character who
was introduced to us as a racist cop who
enjoys torturing black men in his care
yeah it's weird and it's in a movie that
the movies full of [ __ ] a wonderful
performances yeah but it's in a movie
that like has a quirkiness to it and
that is introduced early on and you're
like well that must they're gonna
investigate that and it's gonna pay off
later on and it doesn't really no not at
all you know drop and it to the point
where the movie builds for this
character or Redemption arc ultimately
that the movie doesn't make us believe
is earned in any way I don't want that
dude to be a hero because he's never in
any way accounted for and expressed any
sort of desire for forgiveness for his
actions right
and so just watching the the swirling
Golden Globe unis around this movie and
hey it's amazing it's awesome and there
was a sense that the the Foreign Press
the Hollywood Foreign Press made up of
like 30 guys who don't live here had a
checklist be like I understand what
Trump's America is like because I saw
three billboards you know I understand
what the middle of America feels like
because I saw this movie and I
understand the race issues in America
because I saw this movie
a movie which does not in any way really
deal with any of those issues the
performance is a great like Sam Rockwell
deserves it like you did a great job
Frances McDorman is always great but the
movie itself is a little problematic for
me you wrote for The Guardian that's
like pretty that's legit ma'am I do I
mean mark has written as we all know for
a lot of public agency W hollowed
reporter playboy LA Times I'm sure
there's others I'm forgetting but the
Guardian is like that's like where news
is born yeah and it's with an accent -
yeah that kind of cool class it sounds
smarter than it is that's very cool
but wait did you ask you to nation no
I'm good mark you know one of the few
writers who would say that anyway so in
a time that we have like a superhero
movie every week every month do you
think that even though we have Marvel
and DC competing like literally every
week and Marvel's kind of winning they
can collide and do Marvel vs. DC finally
in a movie and if so how would you guys
write it I I do I think well I I gotta
say were within ten years of seeing a
Marvel vs. DC Marvel don't need it right
now obviously they're doing fine but at
the same time you know I don't know well
you know it's all depends on how
interesting they could keep this story
they're telling going in the Marvel
Universe Cinematic Universe after the
next Avengers the two Avengers movies
they keep promising like this is gonna
change the landscape altogether does it
change the landscape to the point where
people start reacting like people have
reacted last Jedi with like there's a my
[ __ ] Star Wars and turn their back on
it maybe the numbers drop a little bit
at that point you know [ __ ] yeah you
want to get people interested again hey
man let's call Warner Brothers and help
these fools out so I could see it
happening but right now they really
don't need it so it won't happen for
probably at least like a decade yeah I
think I think it requires a giant
[ __ ] filmmaker to want that to happen
in the same way that it required Robert
Zemeckis to want to make Who Framed
Roger Rabbit which
bridge the gap between Disney and Warner
Brothers in a very real way so that you
could have [ __ ] Bugs Bunny and Mickey
Mouse on screen at the same time which
was previously impossible to be done
yeah and the contractual
intricacies of how that movie worked all
ridiculous
all right so Daffy Duck and Donald Duck
are gonna be playing piano together so
Daffy enters the scene first so Donald
gets it Edythe scene last they both knew
the same number of lines and they both
have the same number of shots because no
character can be seen to be more
important than the other all ducks are
created lethal I think if JJ decides
that he's got a superhero story he wants
to tell and goes to Disney and Marvel
said hey listen here's the story that I
want to do with Batman vs Captain
America or here's the Marvel vs. DC
story that I want then maybe that kind
of happens in like ten years but without
some giant irresistible force behind it
I think that that the fiefdom will play
well enough alone as opposed together I
think you're right though I hadn't I
hadn't factored that in a star power
could force the issue but I don't know
if there's a filmmaker that's powerful
enough to do that but it's like a
massive movie star like who's the
biggest [ __ ] star in the world
toughest get somebody who would never do
a [ __ ] Marvel movie I mean if that
also matters at the box office
Brad Pitt if Brad the Meryl Streep
Sue Storm she'd be a great good man but
still but like somebody who matters at
the box office let's say a Brad Pitt for
argument's sake if Brad Pitt was like I
want to do one of these movies but I
only want to do it if I can cross over
the two companies yeah Benny you're
right maybe he's money to be made Brad
Pitt goes to Spielberg and says here's
how I want to do this Spielberg that's
the name that would do it if Spielberg
walked in and was just like let me show
you guys how to [ __ ] I need to Studios
yeah he can make it I mean he's kind of
making it happen a little bit there's a
lot of EP cross IP crossover in ready
player one yeah kind of looks like him
gone oh I'm gonna do my modern-day
version of Roger Rabbit you know who
could get it done Lego could get it done
yeah yeah you're right you know like I
think the the licenses that they have
could probably make it so that those
characters could appear on screen at the
same time in a way that does not violate
any currently existing neutrality
agreements or whatever yeah I think that
could that could work if they wanted it
would it be I mean look at that
so far both lego movies that I saw so
the lego movie and the Batman like a
movie we're absolutely an enjoyable one
is like [ __ ] brilliant but if they
crossed over Marvel and DC characters in
a lego movie
does that would you care would that make
you go not especially right but if the
box were checking it is Marvel vs. DC
you could get that done yeah good point
could you imagine that it's just like
you're getting Marvel vs. DC everyone's
like yeah I have like it's the Lego
version but you might get charged ten
more years ten more years
alright mass great question you get a
shirt thank you we'll go here and then
we'll go home come on JC bring us home
make it a good one no pressure gentlemen
how are you hey so uh wizard was a
wonderful magazine wizard the comic
magazine was a wonderful magazine they
had a segment that I believe we all
loved
who would you cast yes Justice League
some say fell short some say was awesome
we got to come up with the next Justice
League movie who do you cast as Darkseid
as Darkseid
who do you cast as his minions as
Darkseid I don't I don't go the CG route
like I find a way but then again I also
don't want to go the you don't want to
look like rising stars but I don't want
them to look like Oscar Isaacs
apocalypse which you know was a dude he
looked like a Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers villain more than anything else
so I guess you might have to go with
some CG or something like that but I
ain't gonna be a cartoon with a voice -
it should be an actor underneath like
looks like that's what they did with
what's-his-face and fan OHS and and what
changed Josh Brolin yeah Josh Bolin you
could kind of see him in there it looks
like so alright if you were doing
something like that who would be dark
side
not not in my version let me try to
think who would it be
take that [ __ ] shirt back who
said that
the only one I hear is who was the voice
of Lex Luthor and the Justice League
cartoons Clancy Brown man but Clancy
Brown just played the bad guy in Thor
right score skirt not scored yeah what
was his name no squirt no the one in the
beginning the big guy with the big
helmet whatever the [ __ ] that was that
was his voice he has like the voice I
guess anybody could be put through a
filter but I don't know I've always
liked him as an actor I would cast that
guy and in a world where you can kind of
just like build darkside on top of them
Clancy Brown for me what about you
I'm thinking of did you ever watch
Spartacus no you should have watched
Marcus it's really me the one with Kirk
Douglas yeah you want to cast Kirk
Douglas I totally do
I just saw him on the red carpet there's
a dude who played the trainer I want to
say in the first season is the actor's
name is Peter Mensa mm-hmm
big muscular black dude with his crazy
[ __ ] baritone voice like like much
like Clancy Brown like just deliver that
voice but also I think you you have to
do a little bit less if you get a black
dude than a white dude to just shade it
in there but no he's a great actor with
an amazing presence and a good voice so
yeah that thinks I made the right choice
right on man you get a hat for that all
good um holy [ __ ] we were out of
questions we're out of [ __ ] to give away
we're out of time you've enjoyed
yourselves ladies a job it's gonna be a
minute before it happens again I go up
to Sundance this week and then from
Sundance I go to flash so I'll be back
and done with flash February 15th so
that the soonest we'll have the next
show will probably be somewhere in that
corridor but know that wherever I'm in
this world I will be thinking about how
much I'd rather be here doing this show
because I'm no joke I love doing this
show I wish we could do it five days a
week but as soon as we can get back
together again we'll do it right here at
the scum and villainy Cantina thank you
for everyone who asked questions tonight
thank you for the really sweet things
people have said but thanks for being
here man this this is the it's I mean I
was going to say it's the easiest job in
the world but it's not even a [ __ ]
job this is something I look forward to
every week thanks for building something
for for me to come playing man by being
here every week is fun we get to sit
around geek out chitchat it's low-key
structureless I really really dig it so
as soon as I'm back from flash will do
absolutely more of this give it up for
the guy without whom I can't do it mr.
mark barnard and that is fat man I'm
Batman for this week I'm Kevin Smith and
I'm mark menorah tune in next time same
fad time same fat channels podcast calm
or you-tube their calms last Kevin Smith
good night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you